germany's opposition political parties
are focusing on a campaign issue that's
got some traction
allegations of mismanagement in the
eurohawk drone project
the defense minister has been ordered to
appear before a parliamentary committee
the linear this ministerium they seem to
be saying
there's no law against bad government we
didn't pay enough attention to this
things like this can happen
who does not devote sufficient attention
to a major project
either because he can't or he won't
actually in charge of his department
he knew what was going on and he lied
why is he still the defense minister
domestic has a lot of explaining to do
it's clear that he didn't pay as much
attention to the eurohawks project as he
should have
he says his staff told him that any
problems could be worked out
he's been reluctant to make any
inquiries despite the fact that this is
about a billion euro project
denies opposition claims that he lied
about the situation
i regret that on june 5th i did not
express myself more clearly i still
believe that we made the right decision
not to go ahead with the procurement of
the eurohawk
but dimizure has more on his plate right
now than just the eurohawk debacle
earlier this year he got into trouble
for claiming that many in the german
armed forces were preoccupied with
seeking recognition
dimizure later said that's not what he
meant to say
we thought they were inappropriate i
also said that we don't need a school
master who talks down to us
we need someone who will represent the
troops
and then there's demisera's
comprehensive reform of the german armed
forces
the draft has been eliminated the budget
and troop levels have been cut
and dozens of military bases have been
closed many in the bundeswehr believe
that these reforms are headed in the
wrong direction
morale in the armed forces is not good
right now there's a lot of stress among
our men and women
particularly because they can't plan for
the future
they have no idea what's going to happen
next
the troops believe that these reforms
will not make the military fit for the
future
but de mesiere stubbornly continues to
stay his course
we need a new defence minister who can
carry out reforms in areas where they
are needed most
and then
also faces problems with several
armament projects
for example the a400m transport aircraft
was supposed to be deployed in 2009
but there were delays now reports say
the transport will finally be deployed
at the end of next year
the eurofighter project has been plagued
for years by development problems
and that's added billions of euros in
extra costs
has also cut an order for attack
helicopters by one quarter
as part of his effort to reduce costs
but the cost of each individual aircraft
has risen
so there hasn't been much of a savings
the parliamentary committee hearing
seemed to take a lot out of dimizier
the opposition was pretty tough on him
he waffled a lot and seemed annoyed by
many of the questions
he changed his stand again and again i
have no idea how he's going to continue
to run that ministry
confidence in the minister has been
irreparably damaged
but he'll stay in office because
chancellor merkel doesn't want any more
ministers to resign
right before the election thomas de
misera's reputation has taken a real
beating over the last couple of months
but it seems he will stay in office for
the time being
after all there is an election coming up